if you've seen a joke written down
you haven't heard the joke
that there's a dialogue there's an
interaction with the audience there's
there's a difference between seeing the
words that were in that joke and hearing
that joke and experiencing that joke in
the same way that's probably true for
the most daring jokes you know because
when you're in a live
theater and you say something that's
right on the edge right it's hilariously
funny it's because you're carried away
with the moment you get this witty idea
and bang you nail it but that sort and
that's right at the edge of what's
permissible you take that out of context
it's a catastrophe here's the thing
again you know you can you can joke
about anything but not with anyone
you know yeah that's for sure my
audience is not the same as your
audience
[Music]
hey everybody i'm thrilled today to have
with me mr jimmy carr one of the world's
funniest men the one of the world's
purposefully funniest men which is an
important distinction
an award-winning comedian
writer and television host mr jimmy carr
is one of the biggest selling comedy
acts in the world he's performed in
venues in 40 countries his last tour
best of ultimate gold greatest hits it's
a somewhat narcissistic title we might
add sold almost half a million tickets
globally with his current show terribly
funny set to exceed that figure by the
end of 2022. he's a household name in uk
television hosting channel 4's 8 out of
10 cats and some variants of that and
presenting comedy central's roast battle
uk and your face or mine he's also
performed as part of the royal variety
performance three times which is
something particularly impressive to us
canucks enamored archaically with the
queen
he was the first uk comedian to sign a
stand-up deal i think that means a
comedy deal rather than a straight deal
with netflix in 2015 releasing business
2016 and best of ultimate gold greatest
hits 2017. he's also performed in my
favorite city montreal at the just for
laughs comedy festival which i'd highly
recommend since 2003 with more
appearances than any other uk act in
that time his youtube channel where he's
accrued over 500 000 subscribers and
130 million views was launched in 2018
and because all that is not enough he's
also a published author he co-wrote the
naked jape uncovering the hidden world
of jokes in 2007
and his highly anticipated memoir before
and laughter
launched in september 2021 and made the
sunday times best seller list
so i have a question for you to start
i have to know the answer to this this
is serious business
a 15 foot tall replica of carr's head
was used in an advertising campaign for
walker's crisp and has subsequently
appeared in various publications and
then it was transported from preston to
the wickerman festival i have to know
about that i fee how in the world did
that come about and why there was there
was a a charitable campaign for this
brand of crisps called walkers very
beloved british crisps and they built an
enormous model of my head i mean
who knows why my head's quite big enough
as it is and then it's been turned into
a bar and so i occasionally my twitter
will blow up once every couple of years
when they transport it because it goes
on the back of a flatbed truck and they
take it up and down the motorway and
people just go was that an enormous
effigy of jimmy carr as he finally lost
his mind
um did you say it was a bar
it was a bar yeah they turned into a bar
it was a huge thing you could sort of
climb up inside it so they turned into a
bar
i don't know i mean it's a weird world
we live in isn't it
yeah it's it's weird to say the absolute
least so so your head is a bar okay well
that's an answer and thank you very much
for that so um what's the biggest venue
you performed at i mean i've played a
couple of stadiums i've done like shows
in stadiums but i think like often when
you've been like i said stadium like an
arena like a 10 or 12 000 but
it's very much whispering into the abyss
uh you you're sort of you're telling
your jokes and they're sort of they they
you're just on send and i like comedy to
be a conversation and even if there's
like two and a half three thousand
people in in an amphitheater in a in a
room
you feel like there's a discursive
element so if something happens in the
room i want to be aware
let me ask you that about that
immediately so because i always think of
my lectures in in venues like that as a
conversation as well and i also found
that if they get too large and maybe
that's more than 4 000 something like
that then it is in a sense whispering
into the abyss it's
it's as if
the individual people start to disappear
and then you can't make contact with
your audience the same way
yeah it's like it's that thing of like
what's the right
um what's the right side
you know the medium is the message i
suppose you're canadian of course you'll
be quoting mcluhan the idea that you go
rock and roll feels like it can sustain
a bigger audience than comedy and maybe
a lecture even a little bit smaller than
that like what's the the you know you
need a critical mass for the audience
but you also need it to be the right
level that you feel like you're part of
this thing and you're an important part
of it so it feels like in a comedy show
if someone at the back of the room
shouts something out i have to be able
to hear it and i have to be able to
respond to it otherwise they're not
really in the room in the conversation
so and i like that i encourage people to
join in i always think there's a very
special thing when you become a comedian
and you find your own audience there's
lots of different audiences but my
audience come and see me and they have
we share a sense of humor and there's a
sense one of my favorite quotes about
comedy is you know
laughter is the shortest distance
between two people
the idea that it connects us and that we
have the same sense of humor and in that
room we can joke and we can mess around
and and they can be as funny as me that
like i don't have
sometimes when you go and see a musician
you're just blown away by their talent
you think this guy is just phenomenal i
can't get over how great they are
i could never do that
with a comedian it's not quite the same
thing because you're thinking this guy's
got the same sense of humor as me
you can be as funny as anyone and
you know my in my book is about this
really it's a it's a a case for living
through humor and i think the best jokes
the funniest things that have ever been
said are not said by famous comedians
they're said by you and your friendship
group and your family they're in jokes
and comedy at its best
recreates the in joke of the tribe
within within that space
yeah so
the rock and roll types you know when
you go to a great concert in a large
venue
um if the if the audio is good it's as
if the the musicians are playing in the
sun in some sense to the crowd but i've
noticed in a lecture and it seems to be
the same in can in stand-up which i
think has very many similarities with a
good lecture in front of a live audience
that you have to be talking to
individuals and i always talk to one
person at a time in the crowd you know i
actually look at someone and i have a
little conversation with them and switch
to someone else and and so there is
something that seems to be intimately
and that's partly why it's a dialogue
and there's some seems to be something
that's intimately personal about that
that's not the same with with something
that's more art more more more
purely
artistic yeah i think so i think you can
perform a a a song
in an empty room and it's still a song
and i think a comedy act a joke without
you know it's it's feedline punchline
laugh it's binary you either get a laugh
or you don't without the crowd it isn't
anything the crowd performs such an
important functioning comedy above and
beyond all other art forms because
no one can tell you whether that's a
good or a bad song it's like well it's
interpretation but with comedy it either
makes people laugh or it doesn't it's a
binary response you're looking for it's
one right i think the critics aren't big
immediately because we don't need comedy
to be mediated by critics it either
works for you or it doesn't
yeah yeah so the crowd is such an
important part of comedy and i think one
of the one of the things that i advocate
in the book is
uh comedians become one of the comedians
kind of superpowers
is failure
we're very good with failure because our
feedback loop is so short we're allowed
to take a million
different
chances
so when you go and see one of the greats
when you go and see chris rock or you
watch a chris rock netflix special um
you're seeing an hour of material and
everything works and you're just seeing
the results you're not seeing
the the tireless campaign to get to that
hour the the thousands of jokes he tried
that didn't work the the the wordings
that weren't quite right on the jokes
that did work the the work you don't see
any of the you just see the results so
it's often that thing of like the
audience is so has told him every step
of the way the audience is a genius
lenny bruce said it first the audience
decide what isn't what isn't funny and
what isn't what isn't acceptable the
audience will tell you what's acceptable
if you just get a response from an
audience that's neither here nor there
it has to be a laugh even it's one of my
favorite noises in comedy
is cognitive dissonance and i get it a
lot you get an enormous laugh and then
you get a sharp intake of breath
because the audience
have laughed at something and then their
conscience has arrived late to the party
because the conscious part of the brain
or where the consciousness lives is is a
bit slow a laugh is a reflex what you
find funny
is is very much like your taste in food
or your um sexual preferences how spicy
you like it really depends
and you don't get to choose that it
chooses you some people like spicy food
some people like kinky sex some people
like edgy comedy and it really chooses
you so i love the idea that sometimes a
laugh will betray you
your sense of humor is a more it tells
you something about yourself you laugh
at something that's incredibly
transgressive and edgy and then you kind
of feel bad about it immediately and you
have to you know i like that cognitive
dissonance well then you have to then
you have to decide whether it's your
sense of humor that's at fault or the
judgment of shame that immediately
follows your recognition of the fact
that you laughed at something dark and
you know and horrible and it isn't
obvious to me that that your sense of
humor is likely to air the same way your
judgments are it seems to me to be a
purer spirit in some sense and it's
fascinating to me as well that you're
watching the audience while you're
performing comedy but you're also saying
that as you construct your routines
if you're a really really good watcher
and listener then you try to see what
sticks so to speak you throw things at
the wall to see what sticks and if you
really pay attention to the audience
then they'll tell you how to be
successful right yes all you have to do
is collect that yeah
you're really you're collecting data
over 20 years so you've obviously got
the thing about comics as well when they
when they do good audience work is it's
like airline pilots like if you ask an
airline pilot how long they've been a
pilot they won't give you in years
they'll give you it in hours in the sky
and i think there's something about that
that's very
um i love the analogy because the amount
of time spent on stage is where you
learn that skill you become kind of
battle hardened to that or i suppose the
analogy in your world would be the
amount of time you spent researching or
the amount of time you spent in debate
so you're ready for that it's not your
first rodeo you've not had that exact
thing happen before but something
similar to it so you kind of know how to
respond to that and
it's it's your that feedback loop is
constantly you're kind of getting better
and improving
yeah well you know about about
when i
generally tended right from the
beginning of my career
not to lecture from notes very much and
once i got more
conversant with what i was lecturing
about i just abandoned notes altogether
and the huge advantage to that was that
i could continually watch my students
and i could see
what it was that i was saying that
mattered and and what didn't and i could
drop everything that wasn't gripping and
and intriguing to them and you know to
the degree that i was attached to my
notes and a pre-prepared uh lecture then
i would lose the contact with the
audience and well that's why it's boring
in some ways right you know that reminds
me of it reminds me of the great mike
tyson quote
um mike tyson said everyone's got a plan
until they get punched in the face
and
i think when you're giving a speech when
you're doing a performance the audience
is the punch in the face
you didn't think they'd laugh at that
bit or you didn't they look bored and
they're not engaged yet and i haven't
got them and i often use the analogy of
on my toes and on my heels at a show
so sometimes you'll go on a show you'll
be on your toes for the first five
minutes and then at some point in the
show you'll feel like
i got them
i got it yeah we're there together
that's right
your body language changes a little bit
and then something happens yeah on your
toes again and there's a there's a sense
of a kind of an ebb and a flow to it
which is uh
yeah it's it's uh
it's interesting because it's a it's a
it's an art form i guess uh that
involves the audience more than any
other and the audience with no training
no prior
uh qualification required
no instinctively like anything about
maybe 50 60 people is like if a joke
works in front of 60 people it will work
in front of 3 000.
there's a real consistency and across
the globe as well i don't notice i mean
if you speak english i'm doing my
performance in english it's really it's
incredible how uniform audiences are and
what they will laugh at how loud they
were what gets an applause break what
doesn't
so do you find a market difference now
maybe you haven't had much of this
experience because you're so successful
but i
don't like going to movies especially
comedies if the theater is empty and i
don't like lecturing to a hall that's
half full because i find it much more
difficult to
to get that response that you were
describing of everyone being there
together and something flowing if the
place is sporadically populated yeah no
i would agree i mean i think i think
comedy is a social
i think so let's let's unpack that
because the first bit is about seeing a
comedy movie in a crowded cinema is
that's just smart because laughter is
tribal laughter is it's a signal to
other people it's it's remote tickling
laughter is about a million years older
than language it's a different part of
your throat that you're using it's it's
basically remote grooming and i think
it's i mean obviously do you know rats
laugh
yes since you're interested
if you tickle if you tickle them with a
pencil eraser yeah then they laugh but
it's so ultrasonic that you can't hear
it unless you slow it down
oh you did it
about a horizon special about laughter
which i think is on youtube you'd be
able to see but we got dunbar in so
dunbar obviously the dunbar number is
the uh the number of friends you can
have they often quote it when they talk
about social media and the interesting
thing about humans is we have a much
higher dunbar number than silverback
gorillas so silver black gorillas can
only groom themselves literally
so they they you know if you've got 50
55 silver gorillas in a group they all
groom each other a little bit every day
and that's how it goes that's the size
of that and that allows a certain amount
of specialization
but humans can get to 150
in in a tribe
because we can remote groom and remote
grooming is about laughter and laughter
why do you and why do you specifically
make that argument that it's
specifically about laughter why is it
that you associate it specifically with
grooming
well because the the the purpose of
laughter sort of pre-language certainly
would have been to sort of go i am not a
threat
we are we are friends
there is a there's a connector so if you
think of the most basic example tickling
if you tickle a child it's an aggressive
act
that is made benign by the laughter
so the the
so i was thinking a while ago with some
of my friends about the use of of
self-deprecation and humor among tough
working-class men because one of the
things and i really like that one of the
things that working-class men do and i
really see this as a class-based thing
at least to some degree is that they
hurl insults at one another but they
have to be funny and then
you know your prowess your status in
some sense within the group if it's
especially if it's a friendship group
but even sometimes if it's a work group
is how
barbed your darts can be and still be
funny that would be the first yeah so
how close can you get to that line where
it's actually an insult and then the
second thing would be well can you take
a damn joke and let me tell you a story
maybe you'd like this so i work on this
okay i worked on this rail crew in
northern saskatchewan with a bunch of
guys a bunch of native canadians a lot
of them had been in jail like it was a
rough bunch of guys and
when i first started working you know
they're all skeptical of me this is back
when i was a kid but i persevered and
you know i made jokes and i wasn't a
twit
or a [ __ ] or an [ __ ] or any of those
things hopefully and then you know i got
into the group and that just went fine
but while i was there this guy came
along who was uh pretty touchy and
pretty arrogant and uh he brought this
lunchbox box along with him that it
looked like his mom packed which was a
big mistake socially you're supposed to
bring a paper bag that's not too showy
and so he got
this appalachian lunch box and that
really made him mad they called me howdy
duty which i didn't really like and i
asked the guy why and he said because
you look nothing like him which i
thought was a really good joke and
anyways lunch box
that's a good joke lunchbox didn't like
being called lunch box and he got
irritated all the time and so the guys
on the crew and it was stretched about
half a mile down the railway would throw
pebbles at his hard hat while he was
working and that would piss him off more
and so the rocks got bigger and bigger
and you know the whole crew was watching
this and now and then a pretty decent
sized rock would hit lunchbox on the
head in the helmet and everybody would
sort of laugh under their breath and you
know he was chased off in a week and all
that was testing to see if he could
tolerate you know being pushed a bit and
they didn't want him in the group if he
couldn't do it i i'm very i'm very
interested in that there's a lovely
australian turn of phrase which is
typically crude and australian uh and
you might have to believe this but in
australia they have a phrase that kind
of sums it up you'll call you'll call a
mate [ __ ] and you'll call a [ __ ] mate
there's an intimacy to insults
and language and taking the piss out of
each other
there's an intimacy to that that's
because it's it's family it's it's
friendship it's uh it's a connection and
i think language is so nuanced like if
you if you just take the
if you take the humor out of it
it's you know you're just being brutal
but the
sort of like it's sort of like we love
each other so much that we can trade
blows and that doesn't even matter it's
something like that it's the it's the uh
it's
i suppose it gets to that thing of you
know uh love is unconditional
uh
friendship isn't so it kind of gets to a
thing of going listen if you if you love
each other you can you can sort of take
this and it's fine and the badge of
honor of being able to take a joke sort
of almost the worst thing you could say
about someone british's art he can't
take a joke yeah yeah well it's in
it's fun being a canadian in
relationship to comedy because
we i watched a fair bit of british
comedy when i grew up i loved monty
python which i discovered when i was 12
and i just i thought it was actually a
circus show when i first watched it and
i thought what the hell is this and then
my dad turned out to like it too which i
thought was extremely bizarre and so
what i loved about the british brit
comedy in particular i think this is
characteristic of your culture is that
british comedians tend to be extremely
self-deprecating and british satire is
like that too it's they're after
themselves a lot and
americans really didn't have a great
hand for satire i didn't think until the
simpsons came along that was the first
truly self-satisf satirical comedy that
i had seen coming out of the us
style or lenny bruce or any of those
kind of greats would it would have been
a huge influence of that i mean you know
the simpsons didn't come out of nowhere
it would have been standing on the
shoulder of giants as is always the way
with comedy you know we're kind of part
of a very proud tradition that goes back
through
uh variety and court jesters and
trickster gods we're part of that
tradition where outside
looking in we're we're slightly other i
mean it's that thing of you know
comedians in a room of 3000 people are
we the one person facing the wrong way
that kind of
sums us up as a group yeah well that's
that's that's kind of the position of
artists in general you know because
artists tend to be outside the well you
say the traditional competence
hierarchies they're they're viewers from
the outside and observers and so
they're they're not in the hierarchy in
some sense and i do think that that's
true of comedians and the fact that the
jester is the only person that can tell
the king the truth is extremely
interesting and also it's interesting
that the king who can't tolerate his
gesture has become a tyrant that's a way
of telling yeah it's a great story about
the great wall of china do you know that
story when the emperor was building the
great wall i mean it nearly bankrupt the
kingdom the great wall of china and the
plan was to paint it red that was always
the plan we're going to paint it we're
painting it red
and the jester made so many jokes
about painting it and how it would
bankrupt them and how it would destroy
the kingdom and made all the jokes that
the the emperor changed his mind so
we're going to need to paint it it's
crazy uh but it's an interesting kind of
thing of like the the effect that sort
of speaking truth to power is not an
easy thing to do it's much easier to get
your point across if everyone's laughing
yeah that's for sure well i also thought
when i was lecturing when when i was at
harvard i was lecturing about the most
serious things i could think of and it
was usually about
totalitarianism and atrocity like really
dark things and this thought always came
in my mind it was like look if you
really mastered this you wouldn't be so
dead serious about it you'd be able to
do it with a light touch like with a bit
of comedy and i thought jesus how can
that possibly be true given the topics
that i'm addressing but i've certainly
come to realize that i'm at my best as a
lecturer when i can when i'm not so dead
serious and maybe possessed by a certain
amount of anger when i can leave in what
i'm saying with jokes i'm in the right
place then well i mean the audience
loves that i mean but in the macro and
the micro because i mean if you look at
totalitarian states
not fame for their sense of humor i mean
they are cabaret yeah they're not funny
well but cabaret is really interesting
as a piece because the idea that cabaret
clubs in germany were shut down because
they realized you can't hate someone
you're laughing with and laughter builds
a bridge it's it's it's tough to be
uh a racist when you're laughing with a
comedian from a different ethnicity it
only does kind of
it makes bonds in society and it you
know joins things up and you know
russell peters really has done that well
i think
yeah the idea that you kind of bring
lots of different people together and
sort of and share that common experience
um so yeah i think there's there's
something in in you know and actually
when you're when you're doing a lecture
about something incredibly serious to to
be able to make a point about something
and to be funny about it is
kind of magnificent because it shows
uh confidence
and uh competency and being able to be a
little bit self-deprecating and taking
oneself too seriously it's kind of it's
all to the good
yeah well it's a mark of transcendence i
think in some part right because you
know if you do something stupid and then
you laugh at yourself it's like
simultaneously you're the fool but
you're also the thing that can look at
the fool and say well i'm a fool but i
can do better and i don't have to take
that well seriously
yeah isn't there something with life
with uh you know if you look at the
mental health crisis that's going on
globally at the moment
it's about perspective
you know comedy offers perspective in a
way that i think is incredibly profound
uh and meaningful to me because you look
at you know what uh suicides like the
extreme example right so suicide is the
is the uh is a symptom of depression and
depression is it's it's basically
suicide is the
the permanent solution to a temporary
problem
and comedy is very good at lending
perspective are going look this is let's
step back from this we all [ __ ] yeah and
the question is where are you stepping
back to do you think like if you make a
joke about an extremely serious subject
you know and you're stepping back
somewhere right and you're sharing that
with the audience and they go there too
where is it do you think it's going when
you step back i think it's processing i
think there's a sense in which when we
joke about something
we're taking something that's
uh too horrific to talk about to to
acknowledge and we're we're making it
okay so that theory of benign violation
on comedy comes up the idea that you go
we're taking things that are violations
in our culture in our world and we're
making them benign by laughing about
them we're taking away their power so if
you imagine the venn diagram of
violations and we're making them benign
and joking about them and processing
that thought it's a very important part
of our because so much of life is uh is
is is terrible and
so much of our culture is you know um
assuming obviously you know it is uh
the observation of decay that's the
phrase is that it's the we're trying to
hide death
we're trying to not think about
mortality
or to transcend it or to transcend it
you know it's i don't think comedy is
denial i think it's genuine
transcendence and you know that idea
that you take away someone's power with
laughter it's like that's actually
literally true when i used to work out i
had a couple of friends i worked out
with a lot and they were pretty damn
funny and one of the things we would do
when we were bench pressing and
sometimes heavy weights is make the guy
laugh and you cannot
exert muscular force when you're
laughing and that's where the phrase
sort of collapse into laughter comes so
that's really interesting
physiologically in the book about what
happens in the vegas
stays in the vegas now what happens to
you from a physiological point of view
when you laugh is i think fascinating i
mean it's really i like to think of
myself as a as a drug dealer
i'm a drug dealer but the drugs are
already on the audience
this is i'm never going to get taken by
by uh the the the police because i'm
releasing endorphins but you've got the
endorphins on you you're getting
dopamine
because dopamine mediates positive
emotion and so and and all cocaine and
and the drugs the psychomotor stimulants
are very potent dopamine releasers and
so it's literally the case that when you
laugh and facilitate positive emotion
you are activating that circuit without
harm right and it's the without harm
yeah and i sort of view uh you know
watching things on screens as fentanyl
it's a it's a substitute it's not the
real thing you need the real thing
when you watch it on a screen it's like
that those drugs are being cut up
someone stepped on that cocaine you need
the pure thing of like being in a room
with other people
that's where you release it you don't
laugh in the same way
when you're watching your favorite
you know if you see monty python on a
screen you laugh but if you go and see
them live if you go you know they did
that talk show it's a different order of
laughter you're falling about it's a
it's and you you know as you say you
collapse into laughter you you have bits
of laughter you feel like that yeah you
know what it does for the vagus nerve
that tells your body you can digest your
food it calms you it's it's it's perfect
and it's uh i think it's a necessary
part of you yeah do you have any idea
what the movement of the abdomen that's
associated with laughter does
physiologically
uh yeah i mean i've
i mean i've kind of looked into i
wouldn't be the expert on that but the
idea that it does
allow you to
uh digest and to process in a way that's
uh you know very
very beneficial it doesn't have any
negative effects after if you could buy
a drug that did what laughter did
with the amount of side effects that
laughter has which is literally none
it's it would be the perfect drug
and so that that idea about about having
to be there with the people that's
interesting too because i'm going back
on tour i did a tour in 2018 and i think
it sold just about as many tickets as
yours by the way haha and so um
anyhow i'm going back next year and
i'm wondering why i'm doing it because i
could just do youtube videos and you
know they're pretty effective and i
could just sit here and do them and
they're pretty fun but i really want to
do it i really find it ridiculously
exciting and part of it is the feedback
from the audience right that there's an
i get informed by that in a way it's
more than that you're giving people an
experience
because i i couldn't you never forget
who you saw lying
you never forget who you saw live you
you know no no one goes the rolling
stones did i see them live or not i
can't remember
but a youtube video did i see that
youtube video or not i don't i don't
know yeah maybe maybe i watched it maybe
i didn't but going to something live
going it's also the thing that you're
doing the high before the high
the people that will buy tickets to the
show they buy tickets to a comedy show
that buy tickets to a lecture and they
go right i'm going to go out i'm going
to i'm going to laugh a lot or i'm going
to be stimulated i'm buying into this
this is this defines me this is my sense
of humor this is my kind of speaker i'm
going to buy into it i'm going to go
there i'm going to be with my tribe for
the evening other people that
you know everyone has something in
common in that room when they come and
see you everything has someone in common
when they come see me it's that sense of
humor
like we don't have anything else in
common there's people from all different
walks of life in miami it's people from
16 to 90 in the crowd and they all have
something in common for that for that
one evening we've created a village
and that's a very very special very
powerful thing
uh to let people be part of that and
sure you could just stick it on youtube
and put it on send and that's that's a
facsimile and it's a pretty good
facsimile in the world that we live in
and it's been a lifeline the last 18
months for people but but really giving
them that experience is very special and
also you have to kind of limit that a
little bit because actually you can't
really play the arenas i mean you could
but it becomes a different thing in the
arenas what what the sort of thing you
do in arenas becomes kind of uh tony
robbins
event
and then it's all it's it's at a
different frequency it becomes about
geeing people up rather than connecting
you know this yeah we
did make a distinction between th sorry
there's a distinction
there's comics you go
to laugh with and there's comics you go
to see
sometimes you get comedian where people
love them so much they don't really care
about the jokes they just want to be in
a room with them
you know it's that thing dave chappelle
is that dave chappelle i mean better
category
he's a good storyteller right yeah i
played with dave last week in in london
he was over in london doing shows and i
um myself and jeff ross uh opened for
him uh it was pretty fun it was a good
scene yeah i think there is a sense of
kind of
uh
hero worship and wanting to be in the
room and and there being something uh
i think you know george carlin probably
had as well that kind of almost um
preacher feel
is really interesting that people are
drawn to that in a secular world
we're looking for people to
uh rogan rogan has some of that i would
say yeah i think he's got a lot of that
yeah he's got a little yeah john
mullaney he's got more of that kind of
one-line thing but he's got an
interesting persona i don't know how
much that's his true character you know
he's kind of like this 1950s advertising
executive
middle america suburbs nerd and he plays
on that real well it's interesting it's
you can't really convince people you're
not what they assume you are
you know john mullaney i know he's had
some some issues recently much more
complex and interesting character then
people would maybe give him credit off
the bat i'd say the same about theo
vaughn uh theo plays this bumbling
southern hick and he's very very smart
man he's a smart guy yeah it's it's also
the way that you go
it's there's two things in life isn't
there there's and i write about this a
lot in the book there's you have to know
who you are right that's the first big
journey in life is finding out who you
are what you're about
what your skills are what your edges in
life what do you do best not better than
anyone in the world but what do you do
and that's not marketing work at shell
uh definitely not definitely not so it's
that thing like you have to find out who
you are but it's also important as a
duality because you have to find out how
you're perceived in the world as well
what do people think you are people look
at me and they don't see
uh they don't see an immigrant they
don't see someone that's dyslexic they
see they see a very confident
british man somewhere between hugh grant
and mr bean right so they see that
so you better know how you're perceived
in the world and you also better know
who you are
authentically and i think having both of
those things it's very important kind of
armor for going out to the world i mean
i did your um before coming on this
today i did the you're understanding
yourself
uh oh you did understand myself well
yeah so tell me what your personality is
like well let me guess you're
extroverted as hell you're probably
pretty disagreeable i don't imagine
you're that conscientious because it's
hard to be conscientious in the
community you're high in openness
97th percentile in inconscientious uh
yeah incredibly conscious but the thing
that i mean
without getting into the horoscope of
the everyone's fascinated by themselves
i find it like it's an incredibly
useful tool because you go well most
people are looking that's the there's
two great adventures in life there's
finding your purpose and then there's
pursuing it and most people
don't get to do either my book really is
about
uh trying to share that so i did the
autobiography but i wanted it to be
i want it to be half about me and half
about you and half about like what are
the beliefs that you have to have in
order to pursue that journey what are
the good questions to ask yourself what
what's the right way and i found that
and i knew i was talking to you today so
i thought
i'll be a good student i'll do a little
bit of research and did that and i just
thought yeah are you married are you not
i've i'm i've just just had our first
kid we've been together 21 years and i
saw you toronto you know if you do that
understand myself and she does it it
will generate a report about your
differences and similarities and where
you're likely to misunderstand each
other and why
so all she has to do is sign up and do
it and then you can link your accounts
and it'll generate this third report
yeah it's really i did it with my wife
recently and it was really useful does
it put you in touch with a lawyer or do
you have to find your own way
yeah well that's a feature we should add
like a value-added feature we can get
the lawyers to pay for that if it comes
up then it's really you're not a great
match you just come up of like i love
that thing in do you ever read that
researcher at the love lab you ever read
his stuff
are you talking about the research and
what predicts divorce yeah
you mean eye rolling for example which
yeah
divorce with 95 accuracy yeah and you
can do it within five minutes we often
do it with couples over dinner where
we've got myself and caroline i've got
it right 100 at the time where it's like
if someone displays contempt for their
partner it is [ __ ] over it's gone
hey so let's talk about that for a sec
how about if we all display contempt for
our political opponents does that make
it over too
i think i think maybe it does i think
there's a there's a there's a sense in
which
uh political parties now have become
like sports teams
you you blindly follow
left or right blue or red whatever your
team is and you become entrenched in our
culture people talk about echo chambers
it's amplifiers the left have moved to
the left the right have moved to the
right
and there's a couple of liberals left in
the middle going
we need some the problem with the middle
the center ground is it's not exciting i
want that to be kind of you know i want
to be a radical moderate but it's such a
that's what i've been trying to do with
responsibility you know and to to to to
well
disability needs crisis management
because responsibility sounds boring but
it's incredibly empowering
like if you take responsibility like it
like no one ever
like when you when you when you win
something you never go i'm responsible
for this but you go actually
responsibility is about the nexus of
control is within you
it's the idea that you go wrong i'm in
charge of this now so that's really the
story of the early part of my life was
about going
taking my
uh taking my life and actually leading
my life as opposed to just letting
things happen yeah so let's talk about
that
so you you you graduated and then you
went worked as a marketer for shell but
you didn't like that and then you took a
sideways okay please tell them what
happened i didn't make any decisions in
my life until i was about 25
months so what why did you do the things
you did if you weren't making decisions
i did the best next thing
so when you're 16 you decide to stay you
can get a job or you can stay on school
the best thing to do is to stay at
school and the best thing to do is to
try and pass those exams try and go to
the best university you can so i went to
cambridge because that was the best one
i could think of
and so i went there and i got the best
degree i could and then at the end of
that you got the best job that you could
so far i've not made any decisions it's
been about it's been what's presented to
you and the next step a very well worn
path yeah a typical kind of conservative
path yes
you know so then the idea of being kind
of in your mid-20s and going well hang
on whose life am i leading
where's this going and you can see
because it's such a well-worn path you
can see into the future go well actually
i know exactly who i'm going to be in
ten years time in five years time 15
years time but whatever the time period
is by looking at someone ahead of you on
that road
and then go no i don't want that i want
life to be
an adventure i want to find a purpose i
want to find something special for me i
don't think there's anything special
about me i don't think anything magical
happened i think i was exposed to
uh for one of a better phrase self-help
um nlp and
cognitive behavioral therapy at the
right age when i was ready to go
right
that's for me i'm going to be like that
person so
something as simple as a personality
test something as as as diverting as
it's like kind of i suppose a a
rationalist horoscope is such a powerful
thing because the more you get to know
yourself through doing that stuff the
better able you are to go right what's
my edge what am i bringing to the party
in life what do i do better than anyone
else what am i going to devote my life
to because you make your own luck it's
your your your edge what you do best
your hard work plus time that's your
luck we're all of us just buying lottery
tickets nothing's guaranteed but if you
want it to kind of pay off you're going
right if i put everything into this
it's going to pay out eventually what do
you mean by everything when you say that
and because you made this shift into
comedy it looked like it was pretty
sudden and pretty successful pretty soon
so that's a very weird thing to do and a
very weird thing to do successfully so
what do you mean you do everything
success success came later but i think
being all in when you find it being all
in is quite important
so
finding comedy for me it felt like
suddenly i arrived in a space where
work is more fun than fun
so
i was working 300 nights a year and it
didn't feel like anything i we both had
a similar experience actually i know a
little bit about you uh in our mid-20s
of giving up alcohol because work was
more important
and it reminds me that i i i'm of the
opinion that the opposite of
addiction isn't sobriety it's purpose
if you have that hey the clinical
literature and that is crystal clear the
only reliable treatment for alcoholism
that's ever been discovered is spiritual
transformation
that's it and every even the hard-nosed
researchers know that and that's very
tightly akin to this notion of pursuing
something meaningful yeah but i think
that could be expanded in a very
meaningful way because you you go all
purpose doesn't need to have
a spiritual element to them and i think
it does because it's about your life's
meaning in your journal it might be the
spirit of laughter you know
yeah i think so you know that certainly
i feel that the the you know the more i
read about tricks to gods the more you
think oh that's a very interesting
position in society
yeah he's the precursor to the savior
the trickster is always the precursor to
the savior yeah john about the was the
was the trickster right yeah
yeah christ's fool i don't know if he
told jokes though and of course my head
will end up on a plate um
yeah it's it's an interesting thing i
mean i wanted the book to be quiet i'm
quite sort of passionate about it the
idea that i wanted the book to be
funny and engaging and my story but i
also wanted it to be look there's the
hero's journey i wanted it to be to have
the tools in there for someone else to
go i'm not interested in comedy at all
but i could see how i could do my thing
and if i believed the same things what
would happen for me because your beliefs
become
everything and not not your beliefs in
terms of your spiritual beliefs per se
but the assumptions we make about what
we can what we can't do that almost i
don't know what you call them the unseen
beliefs about well i'm not the kind of
person that does that or i'm not the
sort of person that would do this or i'm
not the kind of person i told my my
niece phoned me the other day she wanted
to talk to me she's 17 i believe
and she just applied to university and
she was happy to share the news of her
acceptance to a couple of institutions
and we had a good conversation about the
fact that you know when you leave to
university if you leave home one thing
that can happen to you is that you can
be a new person you can decide what
garbage and wreckage you're going to
leave behind and not drag with you and
you can decide who you're going to be
and what kind of friends you want and if
you're lucky in life you get a few
chances to do that and you just drop a
lot of catastrophe you're preaching to
the choir here i was 16 and i changed
schools through happenstance
we moved house and i changed schools for
what we would call sixth form so for the
last two years and you become acutely
aware that you are a story you tell
yourself
that you can you can choose to kind of
be i was quite a tear away in my first
school i got a lot of trouble and then i
changed i can't believe that and then
when but in my second school i kind of
went no just i'll be academic and i'll
do well and i'll go to a good university
and then at university you you can kind
of you reinvent yourself i mean the
cliche really of finding yourself is
travel
and
you go especially if you go on your own
um which is probably easier for young
men in this day and age than young women
but you to travel on your own in
southeast asia or something and you you
kind of you meet new people and you try
on different hats and
hey i got something cool to tell you
about that gold if you'd be interested
well
i read at one point jung's description
of the uh maze in the
charter cathedral
and in the maze you you enter on one
side and then you traverse the entire
circle
and that's equivalent to traversing the
globe and the maze is set out so that
you walk all four quadrants and then you
come to the center
so then you're at the center if you walk
all four quadrants now what happens when
you go somewhere new is two things is
one is you learn new things so you pull
in new information and that enriches you
but here's something that's even cooler
and it's related at a deep level to the
psychobiology of play and pretend
so if you go somewhere new that requires
you to be someone other than you were
new genes turn on in your nervous system
and code for new proteins it turns on
biological potential that is in fact
implicit inside you and builds you into
a new creature and so the idea behind
that traversing the circle which is an
equivalent to a pilgrimage is that if
you go all places you get to the center
of things because you turn everything in
yourself on by doing that and that's the
same thing you're doing in some sense
when you're listening to your audience
so intensely and finding out what they
appreciate and what's funny right you're
you're you're visiting these new domains
and and that transforms you into
something well something they want and
something you want if you're lucky if
you're careful and you're lucky i i find
it a fascinating kind of you know i mean
travel is obviously
i sort of think the nature nurture thing
comes into it because you i think a lot
of people assume like nature nurture
it's the debate is pointless because
nature is very important but there's
nothing i can do about nature that's the
cards i've been dealt right so
other than a little bit of plastic
surgery nose job yeah nose job man hair
transplant
yeah yeah yeah yeah
those are pretty nice teeth for an
englishman thank you uh
thank you thank you to my audience
you've paid for it um the but the idea
that you go look you've got your nature
that's the cards you're dealt you make
the best of that that's nurture is
making the best of that the idea that i
think a lot of people have the idea that
nurture finishes very early it's about
parental nurturing and
you know when you're 18 you're finished
but the idea of nurture as a lifelong
pursuit and you can't really beat your
environment so it's important you're in
an environment i mean the environment in
a kind of literal sense of going not
just where you are but who you're with
is your environment so yeah surround
yourself with people where and i think
we're all quite narcissistic i think i
like who i am
when i'm with certain people i like
being a father i like who i am yeah but
that might not be narcissistic that
might be the
like if you love being a father you have
a great relationship with your children
how do you it's perfectly reasonable for
you to assume that that's when you are
your best self i thought that when i was
a father i loved being with my kids and
with a great relationship even that
thing about the conversations that you
have the friends you choose to go to
dinner for the work environment i
remember about arriving in the world of
comedy age 25 and just thinking well
this is
i like who i am here this is fun
right right there's a there's a spirit
of possibility here that i hadn't
experienced before so
success happened very early on within
that world not in terms of financial
gains or status because sort of who
cares that's for someone else that's
very external that measure of success
but the idea of like a happiness
uh came out of that that was that was
transformational uh just in terms of my
my whole way of being changed and i
think
uh you know happiness is it's one of
those words that's become
uh conflated in in the book i'm sort of
obsessed by
the accuracy of language
and how we that's a good thing if you're
writing a book yeah but but that you
know that the idea that i i talk about
in my mid-20s or my early 20s being sad
i wasn't depressed
i was sad and there's a huge difference
because
depression is about serotonin levels and
uh chemical imbalance that bounce in
your mind it's a very serious disease
with very serious repercussions suicide
being the most serious
symptom
sadness is about circumstance
sadness is fantastic sadness just means
you don't like things as they are well
things are going to change
you can you know you're you're you're
not now and you're a verb yeah well
you're going to change one of the things
i did constantly as a therapist so this
is part of the cognitive behavioral
process let's say it's collaborative
empiricism it's like okay your mood
isn't good but there's some variation in
it so what you're going to do for the
next week is you're going to watch
yourself like you don't know who you are
and you're going to see if you can
identify times when you're not so sad
and then see if you can figure out like
where those where you are what you're
doing what you're thinking why are you
not sad then yeah
yeah and then can you do more of that
could you do more of that well it's
interesting i mean again i talk about
this in the book i wouldn't have the
same qualification as you but the
my cure for that is flow state get into
a flow
get into a state where you're not aware
of the passage of time
yeah yeah that's a marker that's a weird
marker that one that you're out then you
know that's way that's where you're
outside the domain of mortality concerns
at that point too right because that
weight of mortality that weighs upon us
is integrally linked with consciousness
of time and in that flow state that
disappears and that means in some sense
you're united with eternity in those
flow states it's not a trivial thing no
it's it's hugely important i thought i
read a fabulous thing i mean i think
sport is is often where people you know
if you're playing tennis or whatever
that's happens to be my sport but you
would you go i'm not aware of how long
i've been doing this this has been just
just a pleasure and i've been so focused
taking your conscious mind and giving it
something to do so that your
subconscious can relax
is i think i'm not i'm not great with
meditation but i quite do i quite like
doing lego puzzles
uh with with my other half because you
go yeah i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
get busy get all that busy so that you
can then
relax
you know i i suffer yeah i talked to i
talked to sam harris about that a fair
bit a couple of weeks ago because he has
this meditation app that he's been i
don't use everybody's waking up i think
is fantastic but i tend to listen to the
talks on waking up rather than doing the
meditations because it always seems
uh i don't know what that is about me
but it always feels like doing the
meditations is i'm not am i doing this
right i might am i quite getting it i
should go back and investigate more but
it's uh well you know you have that out
that you already described too though
that because you're doing what you have
and you're
yeah absolutely but you know we we
discussed the possibility you get in
that worried state where you're
possessed by your by your propositional
thoughts about gloom and doom and all
that's running around in your head and
to get out of that into a different
state is actually
psychophysiologically rejuvenating i
think i've got a i've got quite a
positive in the book as well attitude
towards i suffer anxiety more than
oppression i think a lot of people do um
and for me i try and see it as the as
the negative side of creativity the idea
that all of the good things that have
happened to me have happened through
uh creativity and being open to the muse
but also once you open those gates
there's an anxiety that can come in as
well your racing mind might get you a
joke very quickly on the spot but it
also might result in you waking up at
five in the morning with a panic attack
and i think sometimes seeing the
negative things in life for what they
are a part of the whole is is very very
kind of make your peace with
um what what you know what life is
there's it's like if you're if you're a
stand-up comedian there's a lot of
travel there's going to be a lot of
planes and trains and automobiles and
travel you're going on a concert tour
making your piece with that go yeah
that's part of the thing that i'm loving
doing this is part of the whole there's
you can't just have that bit you have to
take it all well that's also part of the
problem with envy you know when people
compare themselves to other people they
say well i really wish what that son of
a [ __ ] had and that kind of malevolence
often comes along with it
here's a point about envy that i make in
my book i make a very clear distinction
i suppose you could have it either way
on the on the um
on the uh etymology of the word but uh
for me it's envy and jealousy are very
different
for me jealousy is about i don't want
him to have that i'm jealous of what
they have but i don't necessarily want
that myself
envy i think could be a very positive
thing in one's life
because envy for me it strikes me that
the only question that really matters in
life in any given situation is what do
you want
it's the most profound meaningful
question at every level whether you're
looking at a menu in a restaurant or
trying to decide what to do with your
life what do you want and envy often
gives you very accurate pointers you
know because you look at someone else
you read someone else's book let's say
from your perspective you might read
someone else's book on psychology and
you might go
that guy absolutely
nailed it i can't believe how good that
is and it spurs you on to work harder
and to say well i need to be more
succinct in my language and i need to
clarify
better or for me i might watch someone's
comedy special and just go
oh that blew my mind what they did i got
to get better at this i'm going to break
down what they did and i'm going to get
better at it so envy i think can be
powerful the idea of not wanting someone
else you know comparison is the thief of
joy
uh is is one of my favorite quotes and
it just it 100 of the time it kills it
as soon as you look at someone's having
more fun than you somewhere
that envy you know that's interesting to
use that dark that dark emotion in some
sense as a guide to what you actually
value so if you notice what you're
envious of then you can tell what you
actually value even what you want
willing yes
yourself i've got that lovely first
people story in the book about the
uh
the white wolf and the black wolf
um you know that story right
yeah i don't think so so there's a
there's a there's a black wolf and a
white wolf and they represent uh good
and bad i mean you know the the uh
the first peoples
and they say
so which wolf are you going to feed
and and the kind of the the
the colonial white man's uh retelling of
the story was what you feed the white
wolf you feed the good wolf
but if you only feed
the good wolf there's actually a
downside because the the the
the dark wolf the black wolf doesn't
just disappear he's waiting around every
corner to attack
so wait wait yeah you also might need
him to scare off other wolves yeah so
that idea of going well look actually
you feed them you feed them both and you
kind of you use that
the darker things you turn to good you
said well something as negative
potentially as envy could be an
incredibly powerful force in your life
if it tells you what you want and when i
say what you want it's like i'm gonna
sound like an old hippie here but i
genuinely on that question of um what do
you want i think wishing wells work
but they work way before people think
they work
the magic wish not so much but knowing
what to wish for is everything you'd be
amazed how many people that go to a
wishing well and they wish for a million
pounds
she's like it's like they're wishing for
a token they don't know what they want
they're putting off answering the
question
what's the thing you really
want
and it's it's like it's that's so
fundamental to happiness in life and to
finding your purpose finding what is
that thing at the base level that you
want
because the knock and the door will open
ask and you will receive
yeah and that has very much to do with
specifying and admitting to yourself and
then actually working towards what it is
you actually want so many people
that i wanted to be a comedian i
remember telling people that i want to
be a stand-up comedian i remember
calling my first edinburgh show when i
first did a show bare-faced ambition
because i was very
i want this to be my life i want to do
this i want to pursue it i want to be
successful at it i want this to be who i
am i want this this is an identity level
pursuit for me
and the universe conspired to help me it
felt like it felt like everything was
but once you tell people i'm going to do
this it was like i felt like okay
everything's pointing in the right
direction there was a real uh uh a
congruency to who i was you definitely
definitely sound like a hippie now
there's no doubt about that so thank you
so yeah so well you had this job that
you took after you graduated from
university and it was a good you know
solid stable job and so why didn't that
work for you and
when did you know that you might be
funny and you know not in the peculiar
way obviously but the
way i hadn't written a joke until i was
25 i was like a fan of comedy but i
hadn't written a joke i had not been in
school plays particularly i've not taken
an interest in comedy above and beyond
being a consumer and i was about 25 and
i suddenly kind of went well this is my
my edge the thing that i'm good at is
talking to people the thing that i'm
good at is is getting ideas across and
making people laugh was such an
important part of my life
um i trace it back to my mother i trace
it back to she had an extraordinary
laugh
she was a very funny irish woman uh uh
had a lovely turn of phrase and there
was a high
value put on making people laugh in our
house because could you make her laugh
yeah it wasn't a particularly happy home
but and i think if you're talking to
comedians i think the question to ask
is people often people ask about you
know depression and in comedians because
the tears the clown thing is so it's
such a delicious irony why wouldn't you
ask about that but actually i think the
question to ask that's more interesting
is which of your parents was sick
i think comedians often have to make
things okay
within their family
and i certainly had that experience
and then and then it was it was about
kind of when you obviously your your
life is understood backwards it's lived
forwards and it's it's understood in the
rear view but looking back
it was it was obvious of course that's
that's what you're going to be good at
you're good at
you know within friendship groups within
family and making people laugh and
making things okay
okay so you knew that you knew that
about yourself that you could make your
friends laugh your family laugh and oh
you said also make things okay
is that
peacemaking or was that humor i think
peacemaking was was part of what what
what i view humor as i think it's a it's
a a methodology for making things okay
for for lightening the mood
for
uh you know
for me it's kind of a palacio i mean i'm
i'm ultimately i'm self-medicating with
humor
so
how in the world did you come about the
decision to leave your job and and you
also mentioned cognitive behavior
therapy in there that that you did
something that yeah
i went when did uh actually when you
work for a large company like chao
there's a um there's a training budget
every year that they're assigned to
their staff members so if you work on
the oil rigs it's all health and safety
training i was working in a fancy office
in central london so there's no need for
any health and safety stuff it's all
fine the most dangerous thing was the
coffee and the coffee machine so
for me i could go and do with that kind
of those courses in those days they gave
us i went and did some nlp training with
a guy you know one of these kind of
corporate away day things
and i got exposed to nlp and just went
oh this is phenomenal i'd lost my
religious faith on a trip to um
uh israel somewhat ironically the scales
had fallen from my eyes and i kind of
went well if i'm right about
christianity everyone else is wrong that
fundamental kind of um
it's kind of a tiny pebble in my shoe
had become a boulder and i just couldn't
live with it anymore and i i slowly over
about a year long period lost my faith
and then i found nlp and i i kind of
thought
i basically latched on to another belief
structure and the idea that the map is
not the territory the idea that um who
who how you perceive the world
is how the world is we see the world not
as it is but how we are
the idea that you know um
i suppose disposition is more important
than position
and
it's very difficult to change your
disposition
but it's so much easier than changing
the world
and i kind of i suddenly
everything through being exposed to that
became possible
but the possibilities became like
well fundamentally my belief became
anything anyone else can do i can do
and that's incredibly empowering and
it's scary and
you're suddenly not leading your life
for the next for the for the afterlife
you i mean i still got a huge belief in
the next life but not the afterlife that
the precision of that phrase
i think the the
allegories of religion i still enjoy
but i just don't i don't believe them
literally so the idea of going there is
a next life of course there's the next
life you move through phases
um
i'm a father now and i i'm i'm you know
in my late 40s i'm a very different
person than the person that started on
this road 25 years ago to being a
comedian
and you know there's
every molecule in my body has changed of
course i'm a different person there's a
next life literally but but the
afterlife
it struck me that the afterlife was a
way of the ultimate in procrastination
and
it struck me that religious belief was
very good for the tribe
not great for the individual
and in our society at the moment maybe
there's a it's an interesting thing
going on at the moment where
we've the pendulum has swung too far to
the individual
and there's not enough tribal thinking
going on
there's an awful lot to unpack there
what specifically
so you said you moved from christianity
and you moved into a psychotherapeutic
realm in some sense and that opened up
all sorts of possibilities for you
started to realize that you had been
hindered by your own presumptions of
some of them unexamined about who you
were and what you should be doing how
did your fan did you have family around
at that time like were you constrained
in your choices
in some sense or not i think i was a
little bit constrained by a sense of
duty that was i'm not sure whether that
was real or imagined i think very often
it's that's one of the assumptions you
make about what i should do to be a
dutiful son uh that my mother died
around the same time
and that was
weirdly quite sort of i was quite i
believe what psychotherapists would call
enmeshed at a very close
um sort of a a
substitute partner for my mother you
know very close you could argue too
close so when she died that was um
crippling for me
you know the grief was was was very
overpowering but also
freed me up to go the thing that i had
feared as a child the the uh the loss of
the key parent
had happened it's the worst thing that
happened and i you kind of look around
you're still standing and you go
you know what are the lessons from that
well go and
live your life the best you can
make you know suddenly there was a sense
of urgency to my life that this is you
know you get one life
mortality became a very real thing
through grief the idea that this is the
only chance you get
you have to make good on that this is uh
right so that's kind of the black wolf
and the white wolf theirs you know the
white wolf you might think well that's
the meaning that you found in this
pursuit but you're also chased by the
fact that you realize the fragility and
shortness of life and it's definitely
better to be if you're going somewhere
it's better to be running from something
and running towards something you're a
lot more motivated then
yeah
yeah i felt like there was a i felt
incredibly old when i was 25 and working
in an oil company i felt as old as i've
ever felt and then the next year i was
suddenly in this other world where i
felt like a teenager again and i kind of
have done since
it felt very
it's it's uh it's you know i i don't
view atheism as a
um
a cold dry academic
uh pursuit i view it as a as kind of an
empowering rush of blood to the head
an incredible
um sense of responsibility uh was was
overwhelming the idea that you you were
responsible for your life and at some
point you you how is that associated
with the atheism that realization i
think it was the the idea that you you
um you weren't living for the afterlife
you were living for this one because you
were you were focused on uh making this
like you were responsible for making
this life as as good as it could be you
you weren't waiting for the analogy to
hippie
you weren't waiting to be brought
flowers you were planting your own
garden you're responsible for this you
better make this work for you so that
that felt to me like
a lot of responsibility but also great
this is going to be
so in that transformation i believe
heightened the sense of the significance
of your life for you by by forcing you
in some sense to realize
well how uh how irreplaceable it was and
how time limited it was that also didn't
undermine you by the sound of it really
i genuinely felt like i was waking up i
genuinely felt like i was in a bit of a
daze
uh
like the the scales have been lifted
i've been i've been kind of wading
through
people
in my early 20s like post college that
kind of trying to hold on to that
previous life like you know talk about
we're talking about next lives there was
you know university was you know a blast
you know had a lot of fun a lot of
drinking great and then you leave and
suddenly you're in the real world and
it's just i didn't like it i didn't like
where i was in it i didn't find it i
hadn't found a purpose that was kind of
you know there's a lot of treasury and i
hadn't found that thing and then
suddenly i found this
incredibly privileged position where
work was more fun than fun so i could
put everything into it
so on that personality test were you
high in openness to experience yeah
how high i think 98 remember
and you're 98 in conscientiousness as
well you said something like that
okay so that's that makes you kind of a
strange person politically because
you've got the conscientiousness of
someone who's conservative and that
would maybe account for your dutifulness
you know that initial presumption about
duty but openness runs in some ways
contrary to that that's that that's the
wellspring of creativity and so maybe
that job at shell was good for duty but
not for
you know the
that gesture and artist
i'm a radical moderator is what i am i'm
like a classic kind of liberal uh
thinker you know that uh
um i i i guess that's where i am so
right in the middle of things so uh
political parties for me sort of aren't
really the thing it's it's uh i don't
find it particular i don't think it's a
it's a they're not useful i think it's
it strikes me that being a member of a
political party now is like ordering
from a set menu in a chinese restaurant
you know you all you order from the set
menu maybe the first time you go but as
soon as you know what you're talking
about you kind of when you think
different things on different issues i
don't agree with anyone about everything
how did you score on agreeableness do
you remember
um i think i was pretty high i'm gonna
look i've got it here i've got it on my
phone i tell you how agreeable i am i
think you're right all right i think it
was i was quite extreme i was um
i was saying
i'm curious about that in relationship
to humor because you know comedians are
often blunt and you have a real edge to
your humor i mean it it can get pretty
dark and and it and there is a real
element in your in your comedy of
well there's
provocation i mean that's not that
unique i suppose comedians do a fair bit
of that but
maybe maybe everyone should do this test
before they get uh
agreeableness no i was typical typical
agreeableness and did did it split into
politeness do you have the split there
for politeness and compassion i think it
had um
uh
yes uh i think i had uh
more
more compassion and politeness yeah yeah
yeah
i'm not the most polite of guys well
it's not that easy to be a polite
comedian yeah compassion very high
politeness very low yeah okay okay yeah
conscientiousness is very high
um
industriousness very high it's a
pleasure to take this test orderliness
high
um uh
extroversion exceptionally high yeah is
that particular both enthusiasm and
assertiveness
enthusiasm very high assertiveness
exceptionally high
uh neuroticism exceptionally low
oh that's how nice for you that's yeah
if you have to have one temperamental
gift that might be the one to wish for
yeah withdrawal very low uh volatility
exceptionally low actually the listeners
of this can i recommend
you i think it's like 10 bucks or
something but going and doing this it's
understandingmyself.com
i must say it's a very pleasant half
hour going and doing it answering the
questions and then understand myself.com
just to clarify yeah just it's it's a
it's a really interesting kind of
process because you go well no matter
what comes out you kind of agree with it
or disagree with it whatever but it's
it's a very nice thing to kind of go and
and kind of assess okay that seems that
seems about right that seems
yeah well it's also interesting to know
that you know that is how you are in
some sense and other people are actually
different than that
they're actually different and so
they're like an extrovert and an
introvert have a certain amount of
trouble in a relationship because the
extrovert is actually um
filled with enthusiasm as a consequence
of social interactions and really wants
them whereas the introvert feels drained
by that and needs much more time by
themselves and perhaps in nature
those are real differences and you know
you can you can mediate between those to
some degree if you're a good negotiator
but you're starting from basic
from different principles from different
a priory principles yeah i must say
those things are very you know they're
very useful i mean that that whole thing
about love languages
i find fascinating the idea that
i mean that's kind of the most
simplistic i think of all the the
relationship tools the idea that
different people have languages
well look a conscientious person would
like to have a conscientious person
would offer dutiful work to their
partner and an agreeable person would
offer empathic love
you know an extrovert would offer
enthusiasm and and joy and so
because those temperamental differences
do in some sense set what we value and
in some sense reflexively like you can
differentiate your personality with work
and you can develop the traits on the
other side of of you but that takes work
you know you're sort of granted those a
priori values and commitments to begin
with in your temperament it's really
useful to see where you might be
different from your partner you know my
my wife is less polite than me she's
more blunt than me sorry
less polite and more blunt than you what
i'm actually very high in agreeableness
as it turns out i actually don't like
conflict at all but i mean i mean i've
watched a couple of your debates and i
would beg to differ on agreements but
yeah i know i know you'd think that but
see what's happened to me is that what i
learned partly
being a psychotherapist is that conflict
delayed is conflict multiplied and so
all weighed in when i think there's
something wrong and it tears me into
pieces i really hate it but i know it's
better than putting it off and waiting
for the alternative i mean that's the
other the other sort of premise of my
book
like is is the
it's not kind of it's not 12 rules for
life but it's got a lot of kind of
there's a lot of life advice in there
and the the hard choice is now easy life
later strikes me as the i mean all
self-help basically says the same thing
prioritize later if you can pass the
marshmallow test
when you're five you just you're i mean
life just becomes easier
spoken like a conscientious person but
yes it's a very good predictor of
long-term success that ability and the
marshmallow test is a predictor of
long-term success as it turns out
yeah i mean there is such a thing as the
as a time machine and i mean it's just
time only moves in this direction at
this speed but you get to meet yourself
in the future and you get to decide how
fit and healthy you are and how wealthy
you are and
everything else besides
how happy you're going to be you it's
all kind of it's all a trade-off and
everyone obviously
everyone has a natural bent towards
right now
because we live
right now
the cutting edge of now is is always
happening so it's always easier to sit
on the couch and do nothing rather than
go to the gym or read a book or whatever
whatever the thing is that's a little
bit challenging if you get if you get
really lucky you can live on the edge
and benefit your future self at the same
time right so that you could fall into
that flow state in a disciplined manner
so that you're present in the present
and you love that because it's so
engrossing and simultaneously
serve your multiple future selves that's
kind of a like an optimal uniting
principle you might say and and i think
that signaled to us when we fall into
that flow state is that we're
simultaneously serving well maybe not
only ourselves but other people but also
ourselves across multiple time frames
and that's an instinctual signal that
that's happening yeah serving ourselves
over multiple time frames i think it's a
very it's one of those analogies that's
so useful it's underutilized and so
useful to think about yourself not just
as being yourself solid state now in
this moment but being a verb over time
so the idea of mortality and
deterioration and also how much health
can you give yourself later on you know
who you're working for you know
ultimately you're in a bargain with
yourself and the rest of society for how
you're kind of how you're acting right
now
um it's very very interesting sort of
thing to
to think about
so let me turn back to comedy for a
minute who do you who do you really like
for comedians who who who do you really
find funny that's cooperating right now
i mean i suppose it's that thing about
you often find your friends very funny
i'll i mean
i find there's a guy called neil brennan
who co-created uh the chappelle show who
has one of the best i think you would
love his special it's called three mics
it's on netflix i think it might be the
best comedy special that anyone's done
so the first mic is jokes one line of
jokes not dissimilar to the kind of
thing that i would do great
the second mic is stand up longer form
material you know kind of routines
and the third mic is the truth
and obviously you start watching neil's
show and the first five minutes you
still yeah tell us more jokes jokes are
fun give me more jokes then about 30
minutes in you're like stand up is
really good the stand-up bits are more
fun
less jokes please and then by the end of
it you just just tell me what happened
with your dad just tell me what happened
it's fantastic it's just it's a really
interesting and the idea that he's made
these very clear distinctions first i
think a lot of people organically do
that in a show but he literally had
three mics and three different settings
and i thought it was a uh
well i i watched chappelle's recent
so controversial show and he did a
tremendous amount of storytelling and
one of the things that was masterful
about what he did was that he tied
everything together at the end so nicely
so it was like the whole joke sequence
had a punch line right the whole story
had a point and it was coherent across
all the story and the jokes and that
that so it elevated it to some degree i
think to a place that just sequences of
jokes can't attain i mean that they not
that they're not worthwhile no i think
there's a but there is a sense in which
you know you watch uh
better comedians
and you go look i've got uh
i've got a ticket to the lottery right
let's let's imagine there's a mount
rushmore of comedy and the four greatest
comedians are up there i'm not on that
mount rushmore but i could be i love the
fact that being a comedian is a task
without end that i can i'm not done yet
i'm in my late 40s and i still feel like
i'm kind of okay i'm in the gym now i
know my way around one-liners i'm pretty
great with jokes storytelling i've done
a little bit of it i've put my tongue in
the water but i'm not there yet but with
the book certainly i'm becoming better
i'm better at you know opening up and
sharing and
it's it's an ongoing i mean the great
thing about most comics that are
considered to be the greats did their
best work in their 50s and beyond
well that is interesting because that's
that's at variance with most artistic
endeavor yeah a lot of that happens in
youth it doesn't happen so much with
well it does with musicians even it it
tends to be a younger person's
occupation so that's and that's not so
much true for fiction writers if i
remember correctly but it's interesting
that it's not true for comedians yeah
i've got a whole i've got a whole
sequence in the book because i used to
find it very
um oppressive when i was uh young
reading about people that had made it
very early on in life
you know child geniuses are really not
when you're a kid it's like ah this
guy's done everything you feel like you
haven't even started yet so i like the
idea of like i used to often read kind
of boundaries with people that made it
later in life
i like
that kind of that that thing of like
society worships youth so much you kind
of i like the idea of going making it a
little bit later is okay it doesn't have
to happen early
it can happen at any stage i mean my
story was of someone in their
mid-20s finding their way in the world
so that kind of the analogy of the
quarter life crisis finding purpose and
purpose being sort of the key
uh that that kind of that that that uh
hero's journey i that can happen at any
stage that could happen in your 50s that
could happen in your 60s it really
doesn't matter
i think it's quite an empowering thing
so you like neil brennan three mikes who
else do you think's great at the moment
um there's a lady called beth stelling
you might not be aware of i think she's
a brilliant joke writer and storyteller
i like uh michelle wolf uh i like
uh
in in the uk there's i mean so many
great comedians uh i've been watching a
lot of my i had a friend that died
recently sean locke who was a a huge
figure in my life
and
obviously when he died the first thing
you do is you sort of go back and you
you look at his work and you look at all
the stand up that he did and i found him
just so
incredibly funny this guy shawn mark
just
everything about him was because he
looked a certain way
there was every joke was kind of
heightened because he looked like a guy
that had he looked like a working man he
looked like he'd come to fix your boiler
and then he was doing this kind of
incredibly surreal light touch jokes and
that for me is like everything was kind
of a heightened surprise because of that
and who do you think were the comedy
greats
i mean i think you know you'd be
hard-pressed not i mean richard pryor is
um one of you know there's a sense in
which everyone's doing an impression to
a lesser or greater degree of richard
pryor
um
everyone's a tribute back to richard
pryor because it's good that he was
named prior then isn't it it seems quite
fitting perfect perfect bit of language
there uh he was an extraordinary talent
and really there's a great fable in his
life i put this in the book actually
i've done a chapter on richard pryor in
the book on the fact that he was
basically he was a pretty successful
comedian he was good he was on tv
uh bill cosby was the biggest comic in
the world at the time um and richard
pryor was a poor man's bill cosby he was
doing a pretty um
mild
uh but very accessible comedy he was on
things like the tonight show and he was
very funny in a suit and tie and he
looked apart the short hair and great
and around
1968 69 his mother died his father was
dying there was the rise in the civil
rights movement this incredible thing
was happening in america and
he was on stage in las vegas in front of
a predominantly
white crowd
and he looked around and he said
[ __ ] it
i'm out
and he walked off stage and he walked
away
and he really didn't come back for four
years
he went you worked it out in
uh in black clubs in predominantly black
cities and
he didn't even come back straight away
with like people think oh he came back
and he was richard pryor he took him i
think it was his third album back
um this
n-word crazy
hit and it hit big
but two previous albums were underground
and he became this
he started using his language he started
being authentically himself he started
it was he was the good was the enemy of
the best he had this skill set and he
turned it into
this he just he was transcendent
he he became this thing that was kind of
bigger than currently kind of reinvented
the form
um it's an extraordinary inspirational
story about
and because of you know the other things
that have happened to him it's
it's literally like the christ-like
story of like because he burnt himself
very badly so
everything
that wasn't burnt away what remains is
the kind of the thing that i take from
that story is that everything that's not
but the essence of of who he was
um so yeah things burn things burn away
if you listen to your audience
yeah well it's that thing of like what
remains of my i love quotes
because the quote is what remains when
everything that's not essential
disappears
you know they you know
not many people have read
about that mythological mythological
memory is like you know balsa voltaire
or any of that like it's all no one's
read the books
but those quotes keep on coming up
because they're just the truth
it just keeps on
like they keep they keep on reappearing
and you know some of the richer prize
lines just keep on reappearing because
you know it's just
you kind of nailed that thing
i saw cosby in edmonton and he did a
two-hour show and he come out on stage
with a cigar because you could do that
in those days he just sat on a stool
that was it the stage was completely
bare and he told stories and jokes for
two hours and
the audience the guy in front of me was
laughing so hard that he was almost in
convulsions his wife had to keep
elbowing him in the side trying to get
him straightened up because he was
embarrassing her but he had that
audience in the palm of his hand for two
and a half two hours i believe it was
and they were roaring with laughter
non-stop it was absolutely masterful
tremendously funny dar uh dark but also
warm
he was a great storyteller it was really
something to see it is i i saw him live
in montreal as well it's it's a weird
one isn't it i think you know the the
separation of someone's work from their
reputation i think is becoming
it's a
i mean listen if we can't do that as a
society
wouldn't it be lovely if we could always
live up to our best but we don't
but well it's also because you know
human beings are are nuanced and it's
and difficult it's
it's frankly it's like i don't think
anyone is the worst thing they've ever
done
but also with that they're not the best
thing they've ever done people are
people are people and sometimes their
work can transcend that but it's you
know my problem with cancer culture at
the moment is i'm slightly suspicious it
might be the new burning books and
and whereas we're very
um arrogant in our secular culture of
our achievements
religion does certain things better uh
religion has a road for redemption and
um
forgiveness
yeah yeah redemption are very underrated
in the world of
cancer culture confession as well right
right i mean that's a while confession
is a key element in psychotherapy
yeah that's what you basically do in
psychotherapy say here's all the things
i'm doing that might be stupid and
hurtful or the things that have happened
to me that's also a possibility but it's
often the former that are more useful
so yeah
how come you haven't been canceled
i have several several times i i was uh
i was i had a uh attack scandal that
nearly ended my career i've had maybe
four or five jokes over the years that
have become
a
problems uh you know the papers it's
it's an interesting thing when it
happens when the first time it happens
to you
it's very shocking because you think oh
my god
i found this incredible road i found
this life of being a comedian and i
could lose it all in an instant and that
is
terrifying and then you realize it's
it's kind of okay it's like you you go
everything doesn't fall away the people
that like you like you the people that
don't like you have a stick to beat you
with and
it's it's often when things are taken
out of context when jokes are taken out
of context like i'm telling jokes in
theaters to a paying audience of an
evening
people have come to see me they've
bought into it i'm not shouting them
through someone's letterbox
at 8am in the morning as they're eating
their cornflakes but that's what happens
when it turns up in the newspaper and
if you've seen a joke written down
you haven't heard the joke
there's a dialogue there's an
interaction with the audience there's
there's a difference between seeing the
words that were in that joke and hearing
that joke and experiencing that joke in
the same way that's probably true for
the most daring jokes you know because
when you're in a live
theater and you say something that's
right on the edge right it's hilariously
funny it's because you're carried away
with the moment you get this witty idea
and bang you nail it but that sort and
that's right at the edge of what's
permissible you take that out of context
it's a catastrophe here's the thing
again you know you can you can joke
about anything but not with anyone
you know yeah that's for sure my
audience is not the same as your
audience
so if you go on the if we if we both
decided right we're going to do a show
together
and
your audience came to the show and i
opened for you i did 10 minutes at the
top
i don't think they would love it it's
like it's a different so then there'd be
overlap maybe some people would but some
people would you know it's we all we
attract our own audiences to come to the
show and the idea that you go suddenly
then your jokes are held up uh to the
scrutiny of everyone on social media
and
the loudest voices are the ones that
ring out the negative voices
and there's something there's something
a bit disingenuous about the press as
well where they'll report a joke yes a
bit
but they report a joke as if you're
making a statement
and
i don't really make sense on stage i
make jokes so you go with it the defense
is always
it was a joke
what do you think the relationship is
between jokes and the truth
i think
and it's very interesting i think it was
um
bertram russell that said when something
is funny search it very carefully for a
hidden truth
yeah yeah well do comedians often say
things that everybody thinks are true
but no one will dare to say i i i think
comedy lives uh at its best
somewhere between
well it lives between public and private
discourse and there's a huge difference
between public and private discourse
certainly at the moment it feels like
it's never been wider but if you watch
comedians are even more necessary yes
but yes i'm building my role but you
know the idea if you watch bbc news you
would swear that everyone thinks in the
same way and thinks the same thing about
everything
and actually there's a huge variety of
opinion out there and so different
people go down different rabbit holes
into their own media but you go there's
a lot and comedians are kind of in the
middle trying to make sense of it all
and talking to an audience and
everything a comedian says has to be
based in the level of honesty because it
just isn't funny
so
if you're just yeah it's so strange
though because there are truths there
are truths that aren't funny
so what's what is it about truth what is
it about some truths that make them
funny what is exactly the relationship
because funny is a subset of true in
some sense um so yeah well i don't think
a joke needs to be needs to be true per
se it just needs to
often the funniest things when you're
pointing something out
that's the akin to the emperor's new
clothes yeah yeah you're pointing out
something that kind of it seems obvious
when you say it but everyone kind of
goes oh yeah i guess
that's oh yeah or they go oh well oh
yeah we're all like that hahaha we know
that yeah so i would say it yeah
observational comedy does that job of
kind of going you know we've all had
this human experience
and if you're talking about something
that's slightly more
transgressive in society it's like it's
talking openly about it so there's a
there's a sense in which it mimics
friendship because it's having a
conversation
that you you're not walking on eggshells
so
political correctness at a comedy show
is like health and safety at the rodeo
it just doesn't
it doesn't sort of belong there it's not
to say that political correctness is is
a is a bad thing
it's just saying it's about the
application where does that work i mean
i'm not i think the obsession with
words with linguistics
in pc is
[ __ ] what you call me i care how you
treat me so i'm i'm very interested in
social justice but i'm not interested at
all in political correctness and i think
the two have been complaining because
it's an easier fight to win
the the you know the straw man is the
language
it avoids having to talk about the real
topic a lot of the time yeah i might
also avoid having to confront those
particular demons in your own soul as
well
so
that's a powerful form of avoidance
yeah
um it's yeah it's it's interesting
one more question
we've gone about 90 minutes and and so
why did you want to talk to me today why
why did you think that was a good idea
and
what sparked your interest i'm i'm
curious about that i i was uh i think
you're an incredibly interesting guy
because i think there's a
there's a sense in which
what you're
trying to do
certainly in 12 rules but i think you
know maps of meaning as well i think is
such a valuable
you know you're reaching out you are a a
father figure for a lot of
uh men without fathers
that's the it strikes me that that's a
incredibly uh
difficult station to to take
and
you you've been given uh i think uh you
know a very hard time i think for for
trying to do something that's incredibly
valuable and necessary and i think in
trying to write my book
i i discovered that i wanted to try and
give something back a little bit i
wanted to try and help in some small way
partly it was about being a father and
it was about having that energy as a
father of going look
if something happened to me tomorrow
what am i leaving my son what do i you
know so from my kind of ego point of
view saying what do i wanna what do i
think about how the world works and i
felt that
my book was something that you would
respond to
uh because it you know it's it's a
uh it it's a it's a much more i mean i
kind of went down the self-help route
because i thought it was low-hanging
fruit in some sense
you know yourself and sam harris are
great but you neither of you know your
way around a dick joke and i felt like
there's a there's a there's a way in
which you know of delivering that
material with a lightness
uh
that that's that it feels like your
audience might might get a kick out of
my book
uh so i suppose it was you know
self-interest but also
i like what you've done
well thank you that i thought you know
especially i like what you've done too i
think you're extremely funny and is that
actually your laugh
yeah it's it's oh my god that's so
horrible
well yeah i mean it did
wonderful because it's it's that thing
where it's a very very distinctive laugh
but i think
i think a laugh got me into comedy
because
my mother's laugh she had a knot but she
had narcolepsy she had a thing called
cataplexy which is a bit of narcolepsy
where you lose muscular control so once
you laugh you often meet someone that
makes no noise when they laugh
so she had a very extreme version of
that where she would properly
kind of just melt
when she laughed so obviously i was
massively motivated to make her laugh
like if she was driving when i was a kid
if you could make a laugh in the car
you'd have to grab the wheel and kind of
steer because she's kind of collapsing
giggles properly collapse and it's uh i
don't know always be very i like strange
laughs i think they're uh they're quite
magnificent
infectious
there's no doubt about that yeah well
look i really enjoyed talking to you i'm
coming to the uk i'm going to cambridge
in oxford
i'm there for the last two weeks in in
november and i have a couple of talks
maybe i could shoot you over an
invitation i would i would love to come
i mean you know i work every night but
if they're they're during that i'd love
to come and see you speak and i'd love
to see you know what what the reaction
is but i think it's i think now as well
the looking at something like 12 rules
now
um look i i really think there's a
hunger now post pandemic people have
been locked away for 18 months and
they've had sort of we've come out of
this collective hibernation
and it's right what am i going to do
next what's my plan like everyone's had
that chance to kind of go right what's
the next step what's the people are
searching for for a little bit of uh of
guidance and i think when you look at
you know some of the things that you
talk about
certainly in in maps of meaning the idea
that
myth and story and
you know
that the kind of young archetypes of the
term i would use you know they're so
important and they're so sort of
interesting in our in our culture
because we've kind of
slightly thrown the baby out of the bath
water
yeah well that's the sort of thing i'm
going to talk about at cambridge and at
oxford so i'll get i'll be in touch in
relationship to that then well
we can meet in the uk that would be
really good i'd love to i mean i've very
much enjoyed this i thought
it was just you know a very interesting
and free-willing conversation i hope uh
people will enjoy and get a kick out of
it and uh yeah more power to you good
luck
same to you and i'm looking forward to
your net next netflix special to watch
with my wife and crack up at your laugh
i think i think christmas day yeah but
if if you're like
if your wife is even more brutal than
you wow she's gonna love it oh yeah man
it's something to argue with her because
she'll she's really provocative she'll
just nail me with like these most she
can string together more vicious
one-liners than anyone i've ever heard
and sometimes i'll just be in a frenzy
because i'm so angry and she makes me
laugh
more vicious one-liners than anyone oh
i'll take that
well maybe you'll get the pleasure of
meeting her but you won't see her at her
best i'm afraid yeah i mean lots of
times in the middle of fights we've been
having we're both like irate you know at
each other and she'll say something so
unbelievably vicious and horrible and
then follow it up with something even
worse it's
it cracks me up it's i just can't
believe she can do it it's really quite
something it's great but that's kind of
what there isn't enough of in the world
like proper debate everyone it strikes
me that we're like in in the culture
wars
it's like world war one everyone's in
their trenches and no one's getting out
to have a little look around in a chat
in a
you know discourse
it's it's that's where the game is
played the discourse is everything and
and it strikes me that that's happening
now
on youtube because academia is
there's only there's only one team have
turned up to play and so you go well
that idea of going there has to be a
discourse and there's gonna be
there'll be a breakthrough there'll be
but i think it's gonna come from
you know
popular science books and youtube videos
is going to be where people find their
way
yeah and from comedy
yes for sure man obviously yeah a little
bit of my relief along the way well a
pleasure tony thank you so much i really
appreciate it my pleasure man thanks
very much for talking to me today and i
hope to see you in the uk and good luck
on your tour see in uk
and in montreal next summer the greatest
city in the world
yeah it's a great place man i love
montreal you know how in somewhat
montreal it's uh it's uh
french food american portions
the best and it's also north american
plumbing and european charm
yeah that does it that's it up all right
look well let's leave it there i'll
speak again take care ciao man
[Music]
you